the Church of England voted to allow
women to become bishops and just last
money the church appointed its first
female senior bishop to the bishop brick
of Gloucester wait wait a minute did she
did you say bishop brick yes bishop
brick the territory a bishop controls is
called a bishopric so this woman has a
bishopric now
that's right Andy
is it a large bishopric I think so
could a Catholic woman have a bishopric
no no in the Catholic Church only men
have bishoprics so so no matter how good
she is a Catholic woman can't get her
hands on a bishopric that's right Andy
all the bishop bricks in the Catholic
Church have to have a man on top of them
ditches but in England a lady can grab a
bishopric and hang on to it for the rest
of her life
[Applause]
sorry sorry Andy we probably should stop
making Bishop ripped jokes yeah you
don't want to piss him off Andy you seem
a little depressed well I mean once I
found out I can lick myself I'll feel
better from the great sugar knife from
the new I'd like to do a whole week like
this maybe rosette major rosario dawson
let me sit on her lap
you